tu crois que j'ai un trip je tombais
daguin c'est mon gars nous allons
accueillir garou garantie sera notre
invité garde et on a découvert bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
comment
c'est un mot qu'on dirait inventé pour
elle quand elle a lancé qu'elle met son
corps un jour qu'est un oiseau qui étend
ses ailes pour ce voulu alors je sens
enfin s'ouvrir sous mes pieds et vous
j'ai posé mes yeux sous sarah des gîtes
à quoi me sers en garde briller notre
dame quel est celui qui lui jettera la
première bière gilles hanus mérite pas
d'être sur terre chanter juste pour nous
ce soir on a fait les belles mais juste
dans les led valérie bénaïm pour les
parents russes c'est sacha oui ibos les
huitièmes nier nier le risque est pas qu
il ya toujours dire vous loupé le 2
octobre
vous aviez chanter sous le vent et bien
ce soir vous allez chanter dans leur
enlevant vous venez avec moi mon gars
comme si ce
tu sors
je suis
est ce le diable
pour détourner les yeux de dieu
mal
kiabi dont on être ce désir charnel
[Musique]
j'y vais
la désirait pied droit
là
garou moi je suis c'est cuit très très
fan de lui sa voix sans déconner moi
j'aurais eu la voix de garde est ce que
vous auriez fr est une machine avec les
meufs le trenta même pas besoin de te
déplacer au téléphone elle te kiffe déjà
non mais sans déconner on ne m'appelle
on n'avait pas ça fait peur soit c'est
vrai non mais c'est vrai que garonzi et
d'endormir ma ville soit faite garou qui
chante une comptine non mais c'est
réellement dormir mais brown et jack
dormez-vous titre encore non
[Applaudissements]
je le suis
miss tuba un petit peu prendre des bus
d'hélium et tu va nous chanter le
refrain le sol
tél
solide parce que ça altère tellement la
voix et la corde vocale et bon dossier
montre la réaction mais on arrive à
chaplin note quand même pas vous
affichez vous fait la danse du gardien
daouda ou si tu craques usine je venais
vacances en banque
je suis capable si tu crois que j'ai eu
tort respire respire respire le souffle
d'art qui me pousse en avant fait quoi
si j'avais pris la mer
le convoi
je donne des vacances et mondial fédérer
borg
comme si la non là ça commence à
l'erreur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]